Vsauce. Are you still paying money for
things you have to wait to do in real
life?
Well, no worries, because I've got more free
stuff you can do online now, guys.
DONG. Lots of great suggestions from
WeSaucers today. First
from 'fippoolive', Google search.
Why be all floaty
when can use Google gravity? As soon as your mouse touches it, it collapses, but
remains usable. Is it too slow for you?
Well, try to kill yourself with caffeine.
This site suggested by 'illustr8r777'
lets you pick your favorite drink,
enter your weight and find out how many
energy drinks you'd have to drink
to die.
Before you do, use the energy to multitask.
This game comes from 'matti1310199'
and 'OVER9000ACCOUNTS'. As you play, more and more things come up that you have
to do.
Here I am using the left and right arrows to balance a ball,
up and down to avoid triangles and shift to jump.
Too much stress, too many buttons to push? Well, 'hall0fgamez'
asks us why not just hit your head
against a wall?
Press left then right over and over
again. The more times you hit your head,
the more freaked out and trippy the game becomes. Too simple?
Well, 'Sicvicious' thinks big - World's Biggest
Pac-Man. On this site you can choose
which board to play.
Everything's normal, except when you escape out the side you shift
to the next board. Once that game makes
you sick of Pac-Man, do the
opposite like 'ARealCoolUsername' - Anti Pac-Man.
Here, you play as a ghost and try to get Pac-Man. Of course,
when he turns you blue you've gotta run.
Now, I've been a fan of this site for a long
time. Girl Talk
makes great mashups and this site
visually lays out in real time
where every sample is coming from.
Take a look.
Well, make your own music on this site,
suggested by lots of WeSaucers.
Click a box and it will rhythmically generate a tone. Draw whatever you want.
For instance, this is the sound of Vsauce.
Or get symphonic with 'Killerzac's'
recommendation. You have to manipulate
arrows to direct
energy into boxes to hear new instruments.
Or be darker with Webby nominee 'Ana Somnia'.
This site uses your web cam to detect
brightness and you actually have to turn
out the lights or find a dark place
in order for her to dream. Now every
dream she has is unique
and completely crazy, but as soon as you
turn the lights back on or even
check your phone, she'll know and wake up
and end the dream.
Even more crazy is ïœpsycho paint.
This site is also up for a Webby and
it let's you mimick the brushstrokes of great
painters
on your own pictures. Here's Lauren and I.
Let me just jazz it up a little over here
and there.
Beautiful.
I leave you with something new.
Vsauce Leanback. It's a playlist I hope to make
every week that contains videos from other
creators that I think are really cool.
The playlist lasts as long as an actual
television episode, so it's like
Vsauce, but grown-up. So if you ever wanna lean back and relax and let the videos
change themselves and have Vsauce be your tour guide,
check it out. There's a link in the description
and let me know what you think, because
I'm very interested to know.
And hey, as always,
thanks for watching.